you know could I want to say something I
don't want to say I don't want you to
feel weird about it but I'm gonna be I'm
gonna I'm gonna freak out the room real
quick okay uh about him okay yeah and I
swear to God
and and don't feel weird about it I
swear to God all right if you're a woman
I would probably marry you really wow
yeah you're his test you're my type tall
and flanky okay so because he's always
wanted to offset his short genetics so
he's always dated really tall girls like
five eight and above like his ex is 510
always tall girls he likes to climb
trees because you're tall
yeah 10 years
you're five four
well what's up why just because you seem
to I don't know and everyone kind of
seems the same to me you don't see the
people below you don't give a [__] right
you don't go no you're tall that's all
you know oh yeah well it's like at my
level everything is a little bit you
know like you could have told me you
were five eight and I would have
believed you right right right but
you're five six two you said I'm five
six two five six two you know how tall
is he that's Long Beach baby
five six two [__] you're six two
I'm uh six eight
you're six eight these are sure people
don't know six two to six we don't know
we don't live above us
you don't live below I don't live above
you know what I mean it's fine it's
weird six eight there's a lot of younger
people will think I'm like six five
that's usually the guess but if it's
like old people yeah they'll be like oh
you're six ten you're like seven foot I
don't know exactly why there's that
difference but well you tell people can
do anything uh you know who Peter Crouch
is Peter Crouch was a English
um soccer player he's retired now but he
uh see how tall Peter Crouch is I mean
I'll just see a Defender no send her
forward I'll just show you here this
will explain just here's a photo of him
golfing okay
you see that's beautiful that's
crouching yeah it's really Crouch yeah
and he he was like he did one of the
best bicycle kicks
he's done so many like tremendous goals
in his lifetime but this dude was uh
because anyway I want to talk about
[__] [__] Peter that's cool it looks
really tall yeah and I mean okay but
usually with sports I'm not like I
played like every sport when I was
growing up yeah and I was not good at
that many not even basketball which
you'd you'd hope for uh why I don't know
you can't like you'd think that we'd run
faster but a lot of times we don't
because our legs are longer but we can't
take as many steps you know
interesting so in a foot race you think
Bobby could take you oh that's a good
question I probably shouldn't do it
right now with two broken arms but yeah
well yeah um but now I don't think in a
in a speed race if it's short distance
maybe I could but anything of more than
100 feet yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah if it
was like a 50-foot race maybe let's plan
it out for some point yeah you know I'll
try yeah me you and Theo maybe yeah
maybe yeah okay he's surprisingly
athletic and I think that don't let his
um people laugh when you say that
I'm saying it for real though like you
are so agile yeah but Andrew Santino
always says that you're not athletic but
sometimes you can be real real
coordinated right when you're when
you're I think I don't know sometimes
people that are shorter yeah
and he's chubby guy and he is amazing at
like soccer basketball pool whoa
yeah I guess you're right but um low
center of gravity low center of gravity
I mean I I there's some things I know I
could beat you in probably that log
thing
where they put the log in the middle of
the lake and then you try to balance log
Running Oh or you oh run across it I
used to do that as a cam counselor so oh
you're a cam counselor yeah I was I am
tall though so it was hard but yeah
do you date short girls yes like Hotel
shorts dude what's the shortest girl you
ever dated 410
that's a pocket [__]
that's your own living Pocket [__] it
was very recently yeah yeah really yeah
if she's a cheerleader and she's very
little and I'm very large it was cute
but people would like in public you
would think it was cute or kind of laugh
at us a little bit yeah it's like um
what what what's that Blaster master
you know what Blaster Master is or
Master Blaster Master Blaster oh you're
talking about the back Master Blaster
look it up yes yeah so um wait a second
if if a girl who's 410 is a pocket [__]
to him what is a tall girl to you you're
my pocket [__] no it's like medievals
that like clothes on you
oh that's not what I was expecting at
all so that's that's the guy and then
that see that that's the head and that's
the body she rides you it's like oh okay
okay okay yeah yeah so that's you and
then she's right there on the shoulders
yeah I mean if I guess if we like cuddle
I like to be uh the baby spoon yeah and
uh she's kind of a backpack
right but but 69 must be hard no it's
not actually really she's flexible I
don't know she always asks me that and
I've been with all my exes are like
under five three and uh
you can stretch the Torso maybe I don't
know I mean maybe I'm just I'm leaning
up a little bit I don't really know are
you hunch yeah oh Peter Crouch
there you go yeah my udon you know
I see yeah yeah because we had a lot of
logistical problems in ours I think a
lot a lot this is the height or yeah
like he doggy was impossible unless he
wore like platform heels yeah okay but
also think about me with doggy I gotta
like I gotta like I'll go into a hotel
room and I'll have to like look at the
bed and like all right measure the
height and the guy is this gonna work
probably come on my knees yeah it's like
yeah you know I'll be honest with you
it's not my favorite position is it
yours
uh it's up it's up there I do like being
on the bottoms that's just easy and I
like my back you mean your back cowgirl
cowgirl yeah yeah yeah you like being on
your back
what's my name oh I see I thought you I
thought you were saying you like being
reverse cowgirl that's weird you're the
guy doing the girl yeah no it took me a
sec too but no but no what what we talk
I've never done that
what are you talking about that's what
she thought the I'm reverse common girl
first cow grilled me that you know how
do you do that you know how pointless
that would be you're on your back your
[__] I'm up uh and I'm you know I
mean oh my dick would curve have to curl
your [__] in her eyes yeah yeah I've
seen I've seen porn where they do stuff
like that yeah people get really
creative I I you know what in terms of
creativity I don't think the bedroom is
the place
for me creativity in the bedroom is no
I'm very traditional Christian Christian
Christian you know what I mean Christian
I'm not crazy you keep a Christian I
keep a question okay sorry there's
probably
two positions for sure that has to be in
play which is missionary
excuse me cowgirl Mission missionary
that doesn't mean my guesses yeah yes
thank you so much welcome you're
listening right sometimes I'll do a side
thing but that's only because
um I slipped wait what do you mean I'm
missionary I go oh and now and now I'm
doing a lot so you don't stop you just
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's like an
accident you tipped over I tipped over
and I want to make it you know I want to
make it cool I don't think that I'm like
silly can't make it so I go yeah I meant
to do this
oh [__] is that working wait how'd you
how'd you break your arm
oh I was performing at a festival like
two weeks ago